This lecture is about the recommender
systems.
So far we have talked about a lot of
aspects of search engines.
We have talked about the problem of
search and ranking problem, different
methods for ranking implementation of a<br>
search engine and how to evaluate the
search engine etc.
The.
This is probably because of we know that
web search engines are by far the most
important applications of text
retrieval and they are the most useful
tools to help people convert big raw
text data into a small set of relevant
documents.
Another reason why we spend so many
lectures on search engines is because
many techniques used in search engines
are actually also very useful for recommender
systems, which is the topic of this
lecture.
And so overall, the two systems are actually
well connected and there are many techniques
that are shared by them.
So this is a slide that you have seen
before when we talked about the two
different modes of text access - pull
and push.
An we mentioned that recommender
systems are the main systems to serve
users in the push mode where the
systems would take initiative to
recommend the information to user or
push a relevant information to the
user.
And this often works well when the user
has a relatively stable information
need.
When the system has a good knowledge
about what the user wants.
So a recommender system is sometimes
called a filtering system and it's
because recommending useful items to
people is like discarding or
filtering out the useless articles.
And so in this sense they are kind of
similar.
And in all these cases, the system must
make a binary decision, and usually
there's a dynamic source of information
items.
And you have some knowledge about this
user's interest and then the system
would make a delivery decision whether
this item is interesting to the user
and then if he's interested in, then
the system would recommend the article
to the user.
So the basic of filtering question here
is really, will this user like this
item.
Will you like item X?
And there are two ways to answer this
question.
If you think about it, I wanted to look
at what items you like.
And then we can see if X actually
like those items.
The other is to look at the who likes
X and we can see if this user looks
like a one of those users.
or like most of those users. And these
strategies can be combined if we follow
the first strategy that look at item
similarity.
In the case of recommending text
objects.
Then we are talking about the content
based filtering or content based
recommendation.
If we look at the second strategy, then
it will compare users and in this case
will exploit the user similarity and
the technique is often called
collaborative filtering.
So let's first look at the content
based filtering system.
This is what the system would look
like.
Inside the system there will be a
binary classifier that would have some
knowledge above the users‘ interest.
And it's called a user interest
profile.
It maintains this profile to keep track
of the users‘ interest.
And then there was a utility function
to guide the user to make decisions,
and I explained the utility function in
the moment.
It helps the system decide where to set
the threshold.
And then the accepted
document will be those that have
passed the threshold according to the
classifier.
There should be also an
initialization module that would take a
users input, maybe from a users
specified keywords or chosen category
etc.
And this will be to feed the system
with the initial user profile.
There is also typically a learning
module that will learn from users
feedback overtime.
Now.
Note that in this case typical users
information need is stable, so the
system would have a lot of
opportunities to observe the users, if the
user has taken a recommended item has
viewed that, and this is the signal to
indicate that the recommended item may
be relevant if the user discarded it, it's
not relevant, and so such feedback can
be a long term feedback and can last
for a long time.
And the system Clock collect a lot of
information about these users interest
and this can then be used to improve
the classifier.
Now what's the criteria for evaluating
such a system?
How do we know this filtering system
actually performs well?
Now, in this case we cannot use the
ranking evaluation measures like a map
because we can afford waiting for a lot
of documents and then rank the
documents to make a decision for the
user.
And so the system must make a decision
in real time in general to decide
whether the item is above the threshold
or not.
So in other words, we're trying to
decide the absolute relevance.
So in this case, one commonly used
strategies is user utility function to
evaluate the system.
So here I show a linear utility
function that's defined as for example
3 multiplied by the number of good
items that you delivered minus 2
multiplied by the number of bad items
you deliver.
So in other words, we could kind of
just.
treat this as almost a in a gambling
game.
If you delete, if you deliver one good
item, let's say you win $3, you gain
$3.
But if you deliver a better one and you
will lose $2 and this utility function
basically kind of measures how much
money you will get by doing this kind
of game.
And so it's clear that if you want to
maximize this utility function, your
strategy should be to deliver as many
good articles as possible and to
minimize the delivery of bad articles,
that's obvious.
One interesting question here is how
should we set these coefficients?
Now I just showed 3 and negative 2 as
a possible coefficients.
But one can ask the question, are they
reasonable?
So what do you think?
Do you think that's a reasonable
choice?
What about the other choices?
And also for example we can have 10 and
minus one.
Or one minus ten.
What's the difference?
What do you think?
How would this utility function affect
the system's threshold decision?
But you can think of these two extreme
cases, 10&nbsp; -1 versus 1 -10.
Which one do you think it would
encourage the system to overdeliver and
which one would encourage the system to
be conservative?
If you think about it, they will see
that when we get a big award for
delivering a good document, you incur
only a small penalty for delivering
bad one.
Intuitively, you would be encouraged to
deliver more right?
And you can try to deliver more.
In hopes of getting a good one
delivered, and then you'll get a big
award.
I saw, on the other hand, if you choose
1 -- 10, you don't really get such a
big price if you deliver deliver a good
document.
On the other hand, you will have a big
loss if you deliver a bad one.
You can imagine that the system would
be very reluctant to deliver a lot of
documents.
It has to be absolutely sure that it's
not a non-relevant one.
So this utility function has to be
designed based on the specific
application.
Three basic problems in content based
filtering are the following.
Frst it has to make a
filtering decision so it has to be a
binary decision maker binary classifier
given a text.
Text document and profile description
of the user.
It has to say yes or no, whether this
document should be delivered or not.
So that's the decision module and there
should be a initialization module.
As you have seen earlier and this is to
get the system started.
And we have to initialize the system
based on only very limited text
description or very few examples from
the user.
And the third component is a learning
module which he had to be able to learn
from limited relevance judgments.
Because we count in learn from the
user about their preferences on the
delivered documents if we don't
deliver document to the user, we would
never know would never be able to know
whether the user likes it or not.
And we can accumulate a lot of
documents and learn from the entire
history and all these modules would
have to be optimized to maximize the
utility.
So how can we build such a system?
And there are many different approaches.
here.
Here we're going to talk about how to extend
retrieval system.
A search engine for information
filtering.
Again, here's why.
We've spent a lot of time to talk about
the search engines because it's
actually not very hard to extend the
search engine
for information filtering. So here's
the basic idea for extending a
retrieval system for information
filtering.
First we can reuse a lot of retrieval
techniques to do scoring, right, so we
know how to score documents against
queries, etc.
We can measure the similarity between
profile text, description and document,
and then we can use the score threshold
for the filtering decision.
We do retrieval, and then we kind of
find the scores of documents and then
we apply a threshold to see
whether document is passing the
threshold or not, and if it's passing
the threshold we are going to say it's
relevant, and we're going to deliver it
to the user.
And another component that we have to
add is for is of course to learn from
the history and here we can use the
traditional feedback techniques to
learn to improve scoring.
And we know Rocchio can be used for
scoring improvement.
And but we have to develop a new
approaches to learn how to set the
threshold and we need to set it
initially and then we have to learn how
to update the threshold overtime.
So here's what the system might look
like if we just generalize the vector
space model for filtering problems.
Right, so you can see the
document vector could be fed into a
scoring module which is already exists
in a search engine that implements a
vector space model and the profile will
be treated as a query essentially and
then the profile vector can be matched
with the document vector to generate
the score.
And then this score would be fed into a
threshold module that would say yes
or no, and then the evaluation would be
based on utility for the filtering
results.
If it says yes and then the documents
will be sent to the user and then the
user could give some feedback and the
feedback information would have been
,would be used to both adjust to the
threshold and to adjust the vector
representation so the vector learning
is essentially the same as query
modification or feedback.
in the case of search. The threshold of
learning is new component that we need
to talk a little bit more about.